[Applaudissements]
participer au festival de cannes un rêve
pour beaucoup et notamment pour les
étudiants de cinéma décrocher une
accréditation accéder au palais et aux
projections deux étudiants de 3e à l
encours l'institut de l'image et du son
font partie est des privilégiés au short
film corner l'espace des courts métrages
françois auteur et edward agents ont
inscrit dolores maria
[Musique]
françois edouard vous cosigné donc vous
co réalisé le court métrage dolores
marie a de quoi parle ce court métrage
est alors c'est l'histoire de quatre
kidnappeurs plus ou moins doués qui vont
enlever maria dolores qui pensent enlevé
marée de leur est la fille d'un banquier
et qu'ils vont finalement levée de leur
est marié à la fille d'un mafieux
pourquoi avoir choisi cet angle mais
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à à parler
de ça ce qui nous a poussé à parler de
ça donc c'est bah c'est surtout le
travail sur le genre on voulait
s'attaquer à un film particulier donc
qu'ils sont bien connus et connotés dans
le final cinéma et est un peut
s'inspirer de tout ce qui nous fait
vibrer dans le cinéma personnellement
est ce qu'on aime voir et ressentir en
tant que spectateur parce qu'on apprend
c'est au spectateur en premier voilà
puisque vous pouvez apporter le film
comme émotion c'est votre premier
festival à tous les deux oui c'est notre
premier festival reçoit également oui
c'est la première fois qu'on participe à
un festival très bien qu'est ce que ça
représente pour un étudiant de troisième
un étudiant en cinéma en audiovisuel
c'est ça représente d'être ici c'est une
formidable opportunité de faire des
rencontres
premièrement de aussi de lancer dans le
bain de ce métier de l'univers du monde
du cinéma et je pense que
voilà je pense que c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire pour françois ouais c'est
un secret pour personne que les contacts
sont très importants dans le milieu du
cinéma surtout pour les jeunes cinéastes
donc c'est important de rencontrer du
monde est de présenter son travail pour
pouvoir peut-être trouvé des
collaborations justement ça sera ma
dernière question quel est le programme
sur place vous avez prévu peut-être
quelques rendez vous est pour pour faire
du business peut être il ya quelques
rendez-vous qui sont organise justement
dans le cadre du chantier corner qui
nous permettent de rencontrer des
professionnels
dans la production même dans l'écriture
pour nos prochains projets qu'on est en
train comme nous sommes en train de
développer ces rencontres et même par
hasard parfois on rencontre parfois dans
les soirées parfois au détour d'une rue
de rencontrer des producteurs et tout ça
donc c'est plutôt plutôt enrichissant
comme expérience
eh bien on vous souhaite un bon festival
merci françois edouard merci merci
[Musique]
le film du jour subventionnées par la
région ile de france et réalisé par
l'italien stefano savona et sa mounir
road prend forme dans la périphérie de
gaza où une famille s'apprête à célébrer
un mariage
la première fait depuis longtemps après
les ravages de la guerre contre israël
face au ghana
[Musique]
la chaîne à des bulldozers
on quittait la croisette retour dans les
yvelines heures rendez-vous demain pour
la clôture de cannes 78
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]